colombia registró 530 muertes por con 19
na xunta más 24 horas el máximo récord
desde que comenzó la pandemia la cifra
más elevada la tuvo bogotá que está en
crisis hospitalaria por el tercer pico
de la pandemia y tiene su sistema
hospitalario colapsado desde hace varios
días por lo que pacientes graves están
siendo remitidos a otras ciudades
ar quien tiene a superior a 70 mil
muertes porque hoy 19 este sábado al
notificar 400 fallecimientos en las
últimas 24 horas el país atraviesa un
vertiginoso aumento de los casos con
creciente nivel de ocupación de las
unidades de cuidados intensivos del
gobierno extendió hasta el 21 de mayo
mayores restricciones en el área de
buenos aires y su periferia
/ superó este domingo las 4.000 muertes
diarias por coronavirus y continúa
registrando el número de contagios más
elevado del mundo a pesar de que la
tendencia apuntó a la baja con estos
nuevos datos el país ha contabilizado ya
24 con 26 millones de contagios son
convirtiendo al país asiático en el
segundo más afectado del mundo en
términos absolutos por la pandemia